qué tal Muy buenos días Pues sí el
ambiente aquí no es no hay tanta
participación como en otros centros de
votación de Estados Unidos
principalmente porque aquí desde hace
dos semanas se abrió la votación
anticipada y los ciudadanos de Estados
Unidos con derecho a voto podían ejercer
ese sufragio personalmente en centros de
votación como estos que están aquí a mis
espaldas además también de hacerlo de
aquí en otros centros de votación hay
una gran expectación o especialmente
porque dicen las que las minorías
podrían acabar dando esa mayoría en el
congreso por eso ambas campañas los
republicanos y los demócratas se están
fijando en minorías como los latinos
porque ya vimos que hace dos años en
Estados como Georgia por tan solo 11.000
votos se acabó decantando la mayoría
demócrata en la cámara baja es por eso
que ambas campañas están focando en
focalizando en los temas que más
interesan a estas minorías que no dista
demasiado de los temas que interesan o
preocupan a la población en general la
crisis económica especialmente la
situación económica las puertas de una
recesión y también la salud o la
seguridad son otras de las
preocupaciones de los votantes aquí en
Florida también estamos muy pendientes
del voto del ex presidente Donald Trump
que va a ejercer también ese sufragio en
un centro de votación de Palm Beach sí
Anthony precisamente hace unos instantes
veíamos las imágenes del expresidente
Donald Trump en su centro de votación
pero le pregunto por algo que usted
estaba mencionando precisamente las
minorías no personas racializadas
migrantes o personas lgbt que han sido
precisamente una Diana de ataques del
actual gobernador republicano la
conservadora hablamos de ron de santis
que se presenta a la reelección que se
sabe de esta votación y cuándo vamos a
tener los resultados definitivos de
Florida
de hecho el gobernador de Santi se
presentaba esta reelección decía que muy
tranquilo y confiado con los resultados
principalmente porque las principales
encuestas le dan de media hasta 10
puntos por encima de su principal
contrincante El demócrata Charlie Chris
que hay que recordar que hace unos años
el mismo estaba ocupando el puesto de
Gobernador por el partido
republicano y de hecho el temas como la
política dura la línea dura anti
inmigrante también esa ley de aborto o
incluso esa ley de identidad sexual que
prohibía hablar de orientación sexual en
las escuelas ha sido muy bien recibida
por el electorado más conservador de
aquí de Florida también muchos ojos
están puestos aquí en Florida porque se
sospechaba que el Gobernador ronda
santis también tiene puestas sus miras
en la elección presidencial de 2024 a
pesar de que republicano ha dicho que su
objetivo por ahora es la gobernación de